there's a super interesting piece in
Politico magazine this piece is by
Jonathan Martin and it is called are the
anti-trump GOP forces meaning Republican
forces starting to implode a mission
control breakdown for DeSantis and
smooth launch for Tim Scott bowed ill
for those hoping to thwart the former
president this entire article is worth
reading but I want to focus on a couple
of different aspects to this the article
asks Jonathan Martin asks will this go
down as the week that the grand plan to
deny Donald Trump the nomination fell
apart
for months high-level Republican
lawmakers donors and strategists eager
to block Trump have described in
separate conversations with me and end
game to the presidential primary when it
becomes clear in the early State and
National polling who is consolidating
support the most influential figures
with ties to the lagging candidates will
stage a sort of political intervention
and tell them it's time to quit and
rally to the strongest alternative to
Trump
such a plot always struck me as a bit
far-fetched for starters because
politicians aren't known for putting
party ahead of self interestingly it's
exactly what Democrats did in the
primary in 2020
uh back to Jonathan Martin yet the
appetite among Elite Republicans to move
past Trump was and is so immense I
thought there could at least be a do the
right thing effort yet as spring turns
to Summer traditionally the period where
presidential hopefuls consider whether
they're gaining traction this vision
seems more fantasy than real than
strategy in fact if Trump does emerge as
the GOP standard Bearer next year we'll
look back we will look back on this week
to grasp why just like in 2016 he was
able to take advantage of a divided
opposition Now understand the strategy
that is being laid out this is a
possible strategy the idea would be okay
uh the Florida primary comes close and
imagine that it's Trump 55 and DeSantis
35 because it's his home state and the
other 20 or 10 percent is divided among
other candidates the idea would be
everyone other than DeSantis gets out
and says support DeSantis and maybe that
gets to sandus enough to beat Trump in
Florida in New Hampshire maybe Nikki
Haley's doing better other than Trump
and so even though Trump is winning in
New Hampshire everybody but Nikki Haley
gets out and says vote for Nikki Haley
or whatever it's not super realistic
the timing of it needs to be just so and
it's not clear that Republicans are
willing to do that but what is being
argued in this article is it's it's not
going to happen for other reasons and it
goes on to say the reasons are
desantis's muffed lunch the fitting sad
trombone conclusion to a
pre-announcement period in which his
stock sagged
um
announcing his candidacy Monday in the
gym of his alma mater
uh John Charleston Southern University
Tim Scott matched desantis's Elon Musk
with John thune and Larry Ellison
um he also doesn't seem destined for
victory
and then there's Nikki Haley whose
campaign is totally Dead on Arrival
Etc the problem with the anti-trump
Republican movement right now is that
they're all failing very hard Nikki
Haley was never inspiring from the
beginning running basically an identity
campaign Vivek ramas Swami was never
really going anywhere
uh Tim Scott I mean again as I said
before it's not all about identity but
Republicans have two have for now for
two uh elections in a row presidential
elections in a row selected the guy who
was openly hostile to black and brown
people in his rhetoric if not policy
they're gonna say oh let's vote for a
black guy instead to represent us it
seems unlikely at the most base of Base
levels and then now the DeSantis launch
where DeSantis is trying to figure out a
way how can I kind of be there to pick
up the Maga voters but I don't really
want to attack Trump to explain to the
mega voters why they should support me
instead it's not a winning proposition
the launch was a disaster the only good
news for anybody other than Trump is
this chart that we're putting up on the
screen right now
the purple line at the top of your
screen is Trump's polling which as you
can see is down from 56 to 53 since the
santis announced
and on the other hand DeSantis is up
from 19 to 22. so we have seen a
three-point swing in polling in the
direction of DeSantis and away from
Trump since it became known that
DeSantis would be announcing if you look
at the very bottom
everyone else is failing okay you look
at Pence is down from six to three and
Haley is at one point was at six she's
down to four everybody else is just
peanuts peanuts peanuts whereas DeSantis
and Trump are the only ones really
embroiled in anything here so if there
is a path right now for anyone other
than Trump
I don't see it as being anybody but
DeSantis but it's not even June of the
year before the election yet there is
time if there is a big news making event
and in my mind the only possible event
would be Trump gets indicted and
arrested multiple times and is simply
unable to run can anything else change
this Republican primary let me know in
the comments